-Recently, Former First Lady
Melania Trump
announced she is opening
the Office of Melania Trump.
Here to talk about it,
please welcome Melania Trump
-[ Falsetto ]
Awwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwww
[ Foreign accent ]
Hello! Greetings to you.
-Okay, right off the bat,
because I know
people have talked about
look-alikes and whatnot.
I have to ask, are you
the real Melania Trump?
-I'm as real as
the Office of Melania Trump.
-Yeah, so, about your office
What is it that you do there
-[ Gasps ]
What don't we do?
At the Office of Melania Trump
we work tirelessly
1 to 1 1/2 days a week.
-Okay but what does the
Office of Melania Trump do
-"But what does the
Office of Melania Trump do?"
you may be asking.
-I just asked that.
-Do they do consulting work?
Accounting?
Can they represent me in court
The answer to that question is
how much money do you have
-Yeah, but that's
not a answer.
-The Office of Melania Trump
The only office
that will have you saying,
"Where is it?"
-Why would I need to know
where it is?
-So you can
enjoy our services.
-Here we go. Which are?
-Thank you for asking.
We love our customers!
-Who are your customers?
-No one! Anyone!
The Office of Melania Trum
welcomes people
of all types of person.
-I need you to be more specifi
about what you do there.
-[ Gasps ] You need me?
-Oh my God.
-See, Seth, the answers
to your questions
is in the wind.
It's in the smile of a child
It's in the laugh of a baby.
The Office of Melania Trum
is in us all.
-See, I thought
you'd be excited
to finally be
out of the spotlight.
Why would you start up
a business, anyway?
-Whoa, whoa, whoa!
No one said
we were a "business."
-Then what is the
Office of Melania Trump?!
-Here is a list
of the many things we offer.
-Thank you.
-We offer tasks, checklists,
a wide array
of verbs and nouns,
this, that,
all of what is over there,
every single stuff,
that thing we do,
and, of course, our specialties.
That's right!
If you're looking
for some of it,
we may just be what you're
listening to right now.
The Office of Melania Trump.
It has walls!
-Melania Trump, everybody.
We'll be right back
with Don Johnson.
-I'll be right back
with myself!